I'm just talking with Bonnie Ray don't
worry about in America
[Applause]
birthday week so
aked in the 80s is that correct I did I
did Prince called me up and said hey you
know you weren't treated right come on
over to Paisley Park let's make a record
together I love that and um
I said if we can meet in the middle you
know I don't necessarily want to do a
whole Prince thing and you don't want to
do up on you ate things yeah I had a ski
accident and fell on my thumb and had to
be in a cast for two months so I had to
postpone working with him he says well I
don't work out and then I was like I was
like 35 40 pounds heavier and I went you
know if I do a video with this guy if we
if the song works that's really sexy I
gotta do something I said I gotta I
gotta work on this so I use the cast as
an excuse to lose weight and I just I
said you know I better quit drinking too
because it gets you know in your 30s
that you put on pounds a lot easier I've
noticed so so I ended up hanging out
with some friends of mine that were
sober and I went you know what this
feels really good so I lost 20 pounds
before I worked with Chris I love that
that's what did it and that's kind of
what did it because I was so terrified
of being in a video with him and not not
like looking and saying all that sexy
stuff to me and going I don't think this
people are going to believe that
[Music]